hi everyone welcome to our homeroom live
stream this is something we started
several months ago it's really a way to
stay connected and have interesting
conversations about interesting things
with interesting people i'm super
excited about our guest today casey
wasserman but before we get into the
conversation i'll make my standard
reminders reminding everyone that khan
academy is a not-for-profit we can only
exist
through philanthropic donations from
folks like yourself so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
donating at khan academy.org slash
donate i also want to give special
thanks to
several corporations and foundations
that have stepped up
since we went to the covid crisis we
were already running at a deficit before
the crisis and as you know our traffic
and the types of supports and programs
we've tried to do have only accelerated
so special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly novartis and other
folks like the amgen foundation who are
long-time supporters of khan academy and
then have continued to support it uh
going into the crisis but we're still
running it as a at a deficit so any help
you can provide is greatly appreciated
with that said i'm excited to introduce
our guest today
casey wasserman and uh casey good to
have you here
it's good to be with you so
so casey uh you and i go back a little
while ago you know
many years i mean the early days of khan
academy i remember i went and spoke at
your organization and it's a it's you
know what i thought would be interesting
is just there's so much going on in the
world right now that you touch on that
you know a lot of
us aren't aren't familiar with you're
very deeply involved in the world of
sports which was
which is going through something right
now i'd love to learn more about it um
you are you are the uh you're the
chairman of the 2028 olympics and
paralympic games in in los angeles uh
you do a lot of philanthropic work uh so
so maybe a good place to start casey is
you know tell us what it means you know
i i mean you can start wherever you like
and a lot of what we try to do is kind
of dig into how you ended up becoming
who you are
but what what um
tell those of us who aren't familiar
with these especially the sports agency
business what that business is and maybe
a little bit about why you got
interested in how you how you got into
it
well it's uh it's awesome to be with you
i remember our first time i came to your
office i actually was just going through
old pictures just cleaning out
old pictures on my phone and i found it
where like the khan academy was signed
on a little grease board like in a
shared office space or something so it
was like a funny
funny that i found it yesterday right
before we got on this uh today so it's
it's really fun for me to be with you uh
the sports business as least as we
operate we're a service business so
we have two kinds of or two groups of
clients if you will which is how most
sports marketing agencies operate either
you can represent talent which could be
an athlete a coach a broadcaster in and
around sports obviously if you were
beyond sports it would be a musician or
an actor or writer a director but in our
case we're just in sports so it's
it's athletes it's 2 500 athletes across
35 sports in our in our case which makes
us the biggest sports agency in the
world
and then the other side of the business
is how brands
spend their money in sports so
very similar to how ad agencies work for
brands we work for brands on how they
spend their sponsorship budgets strategy
the execution of those arrangements
amplification and then ultimately
measurement and then the other side of
it is how do properties attract those
dollars so
if you're a team a league of property
and you want to understand what brands
are thinking how they want to spend
their dollars what kind of assets they
need to tell their story to connect with
their consumers we help them structure
and package that and so that sports
marketing uh kind of in its broadest
sense of the word we operate pretty much
across the entirety of the business we
have a thousand employees around the
world and uh
and uh sports obviously is a is a
well it's a global business that truly
manifests itself locally so if you're
going to be relevant and present in
sports or in regions you have to be in
those places which is sort of given the
desperate nature of our business
and what is the day-to-day like of of
what you do you know someone who works
at wasserman agency i mean you you might
have to do a lot of things but
you know for those of us who are naive
to this world you know we we know the
sports figures we know they play games
we know that they uh you know they they
get paid salaries we know there's some
sense of economics that there's
advertising there's sponsorship there's
ticket sales so what does an agency do
uh for for the various parties
especially for the sports figures is at
least how i conceptualize it yes so for
an athlete i mean you might imagine uh
different than other kinds of talents
because
uh team sports athletes and individual
sports athletes by the way are a little
bit different so team sports athletes
have a natural support structure
you know you're in the bay area clay
thompson who's a client the warriors are
his support structure during the season
there's doctors there's food there's
travel there's
obviously basketball there's health and
wellness there's
a
traveling support team when they're on
the road all that stuff and so the agent
is there
to deal with the off the court
opportunities that happen during the
season any other things that might be an
opportunity
uh as it relates to basketball if
there's you know obviously
he wouldn't be a player who would get
traded but players who get traded if
they get injured things happen and then
in the off season we help them sort of
manage their lives now on the individual
athlete side like a professional golfer
we help coordinate travel food lodging
all that stuff setting the competitive
schedule actually entering them in the
tournaments hiring and firing of caddy
uh dealing with sponsors arranging photo
shoots
uh
fixing problems when they happen
in many cases managing social media
triaging
social media problems if they happen you
know
they want to invest in a business they
want to buy an apartment or a house
that's across all athletes they
want to get married or divorced or you
know there's a whole slew of things
yeah you know i'm not sure the average
age of the people watching this but if
you've seen jerry maguire uh it's a
pretty good it's a pretty good
representation maybe not in style but in
substance
no i think that was most of our first
exposure and for me only exposure to
this uh but it is fascinating because
you imagine you know there's all these
contract negotiations and you you read
about it you know actually i think would
be great math example word problems of
like if you win the championship this
happens and if that happens if you get
injured this happens there are these
you know that's what i imagine
and you know where the agents are very
powerful and and important and and most
agents have a background as lawyers
if i understand yeah yeah a lot of our
lawyers i would tell you to your point
about a sort of a math lesson
you know
as you know analytics and statistics and
data have become such a big part
of sports obviously moneyball started it
in baseball but it's now pervasive in
sport
that's how teams negotiate that's how
they perceive value and so we view as an
agency our responsibility is to act
on behalf of our clients as you know
take the nfl as the 33rd team right so
we have to have the resources and data
and analytics and statistics and
analysis and financial understanding of
television contracts and sponsor deals
and local revenue and national revenue
and how those all feed into each other
salary cap projections how long of a
deal should you make all those things
so that we can serve our clients best
because it has really become
a very much data statistics
financial driven model and and we need
to do our best to represent our clients
to achieve the best results for them and
it's really changed a lot it used to be
relationships and
oh you owe me one here because you
signed that guy and you underpaid him so
i needed to take care of my guy here and
and those days are not over but they're
pretty much over and uh and so the whole
if you will math of it has changed
dramatically and ironically while a lot
of the agents are lawyers the legal part
has been reduced in many ways the
contracts for team sports are
literally fill in the blank contracts
the addendums are where all the math
happens and that's the interesting part
but that's as much analytics it is legal
so it's uh it's an interesting evolution
of the business for sure
now it is interesting because when you
realize that sports more than anything
it's very measurable the outcomes are
very measurable the economics are very
measurable and so yeah it's probably
more than any other industry uh is is
suited for this type of analysis there's
a question coming off of a youtube from
sudha rani says hi casey when did you
start and so you know just how did you
get into this did you always know that
you wanted to be a sports agent uh what
what drew you into this profession
i would say i always loved sports like a
lot of kids growing up but i was a weird
kid and that i loved the business of
sports kind of an odd thing to love i
was
spent the summer as a bald boy for the
cleveland browns and spent more time
in the front office
than i did in the on the field frankly
so
i i've always loved the business of
sports and and really um
in 2002 acquired our first little agency
a teeny little action sports agency that
we still own today that's quite big now
the biggest action sports agency and
just built from there we were
opportunistic we were strategic we made
lots of mistakes uh and built uh in in a
way that we thought was going to create
value for the client and and make a
point of differentiation for us in a
competitive industry and so started with
a little action sports agency
uh bought a fairly big basketball
baseball agency and then have bought
a ton of other agencies hired lots of of
agents from competitors and built a
really incredible group of business
based on great work of about 130 sports
agents around the world and
i'm lucky enough to be able to pursue
and work in my passion every day
and so it sounds like you you
it is what you imagined it to be
uh yeah i mean i would say there are
certainly things that i do that i never
imagined i would do and certain things i
get to do that i never imagined would be
possible but uh uh what i love about our
business the diversity of our business
is that no day is the same salad we i
get to spend
my days
i really think focus on three things
uh i focus on the strategy of the
company i focus on the culture
which is about the work environment for
the people and i deal with problems and
if you and if you think about human
nature human nature is that you stick
your head in the sand and hope problems
go away and the truth is
problems um usually get worse unless you
deal with them and so dealing with
problems but creating an organization
that actually supports people
communicating about problems and rewards
people as opposed to penalizing them
kind of turns the paradigm on its head
and i think the more you do the more
successful you are the more problems you
have and the better you are dealing with
them is the more successful you are and
so my days are
depends on the day depends on the week
you can imagine during this period time
we've had
obviously uh
unprecedented issues to deal with on
behalf of our clients on behalf of our
business
but from from things like uh when
baseball players are trying to come back
to helping them think about the
economics of that the testing protocols
you know using all of our resources to
help them make an informed decision
about
playing we have players who are play
reps for their teams in terms of all
they represent all the players on their
team so
you know the diversity of what i do is
what i love and i get to do it in a
business i'm passionate about in a world
of sports that i think is you know in a
world where you get to you don't always
get to pick what you do i'm lucky to get
to do it in all the sports every day
and i want to dig deeper into that i
definitely want to go get into what's
going on because of covid because that's
obviously fascinating but there's you
know a couple of folks off of facebook
and youtube
you know you you quickly alluded to some
mistakes and struggles you made but you
kind of gave the the very quick you know
you read in a magazine you know casey
started here he graduated there and then
he became the head of an agency and
they're very successful and you know
happy every happily ever after uh but
you know it's it's never that way and
and so you know from facebook shazad
warrick asks what type of mistakes have
you met made from youtube parole mytha
asking
what are the struggles you encountered
on your way uh from youtube susanna
dominguez
could you describe a problem and how you
overcame that problem so yeah give us a
little bit of texture fill in the blanks
was it was it was this smooth sailing
the whole time
never and it's there's no such thing and
i think one of the misconceptions people
have in this day and age of
perceived instant success
is that success is a moment in time and
the truth is
my view of success is that it comes from
relentless consistency
and that pursuit of excellence over a
long period of time relentlessly and
when i talk about dealing with bad news
if you're able to relentlessly pursue
excellence on a consistent basis it
means that the problems you have you've
been able to get through and overcome
and get to the other side
and so we have there is you know as i
like to say no one has ever come into my
office to give me something for nothing
that just doesn't happen
uh and and the truth is
we're a better organization because
we're better at dealing with problems uh
it's why we're able to get through a
time like covet uh 2009 you know i mean
i've now been the started this business
in 2002 so i've been running this
company for 18 years um
this is now the second time in my career
that i'm dealing with something that was
otherwise supposed to be unprecedented
uh that's unto itself unprecedented
learning how to manage through these
things and ups and downs and i can tell
you
i was at the nba all-star game in
february
i didn't think that less than 30 days
later
the nba would shut down for good until
hopefully a week from now and
my business would be dramatically off in
revenue i'd have to
make all sorts of difficult decisions
and our business by the way is i think
as stable and good and positive we
didn't lay off
uh significant numbers of people we had
like less than two percent um
and that's really for businesses that
evaporated because of this not not
businesses that are just down
and and working through an environment
like this is really difficult but by the
way problems don't have to be big it can
be a mistake by an employee that you
lose a client it can be
a mistake by an employee that causes a a
problem internally in terms of culture
and and and the work environment
um uh there are it can be a mistake
someone posts something on social media
they shouldn't post there's an employee
you know in the end my name's on the
door and uh and my reputation is at
stake and so all those things are
important and we take responsibility for
them and we take
um
focus on them in terms of making sure we
treat them as we would all want to be
treated
and there are literally problems every
day and so
the reason i think we have had success
is because we've been doing it a long
time i think we do it very well in the
end we do it for the benefit of our
clients that's the only metric we
measure ourselves by is the quality of
work
and the longer you can do it the more
consistently you can do it you can wake
up today and i have a thousand employees
and hundreds of millions of dollars of
revenue the action sports business we we
bought in 2002 had less than a million
dollars of revenue and now if you told
me in 2002 we'd be doing what we're
doing today with the number employees we
were doing it i would have said no way i
couldn't have imagined how i'd get there
and i hope in five years i'll be able to
look back and say that's all we were
doing and now we're doing all this and
you i can't tell you how we're going to
get to that point but
it's again it's it's one of the things i
see most amongst a younger generation i
think you and i are is they think that
moment of success is a moment because of
a singular action and the truth is it
never is it's the result of a lot of
work over a long period of time through
lots of up and downs
did you ever have a moment where you're
just like i don't think i'm gonna make
it this isn't for me i don't have what
it takes
um no but that's probably just you know
my blind competitiveness i mean i am
truly
uh crazy competitive and so even if i
was at the brink of that happening i
would never think that because
uh it's just not in my dna just like by
the way enjoying success is not
particularly in my dna either so i i
would say
i'm much more focused on always driving
forward um i spend very little time
worried about what's in the rearview
mirror good or bad and and
so it's not any anything that makes me
better than anybody else it's just in
kind of in my dna
i i i think we have we have some
similarities i have had my moments but
then i'd go on a hike and i said that
squirrel doesn't care that i just failed
miserably and embarrassed you know
myself and everything and then i get
over it and i and i get back and get get
back on track before before we go to the
cove because i think there's a whole uh
many things we can talk about there you
know what's i think interesting about
being a sports agent is obviously you
are running a business you are a manager
you're a leader for your team but you're
also i could imagine an observer of what
these elite athletes are like and i'm
curious you know from as an outsider's
point of view we we say oh look you know
so-and-so has god-given talent
so incredible et cetera et cetera but
you see what goes on behind the scenes
you know what's your observation of what
makes
talent great what makes people have
enduring and really successful careers
in sports and maybe what's surprising
relative to what most people think
well i would say the two things that are
maybe one surprising one not but that
one they are the the elite athletes are
willing to make sacrifices in some or
significant parts of their lives to be
the best at what they do
and people don't like to admit that or
own that but there you cannot do it all
and they are they have chosen to make
those sacrifices to dedicate themselves
to their craft to be at that level
obviously if anybody watched the last
dance
on espn about michael jordan he made
incredible sacrifices
and incredible dedication to his craft
and that's what made him elite in
addition to clearly god-given talent at
a level maybe we've never seen before
the other piece of it is
athletes are human beings
they have all the same insecurities
anxieties fears concerns worries ups
downs
issues with kids partners loved ones
parents
finances good bad like they are people
and all that stuff affects them and
maybe they're better at
compartmentalizing them so that they can
compete but they're people and they have
all those issues too so
you know yes they can be role models yes
they ought to carry themselves in a way
because they do have influence but we
also need to understand i think part of
this you started to see with the
recognition that the mental health is
something that affects everybody not
some people
is it athletes are starting to
communicate about mental health concerns
and issues that they have anxiety kevin
love couldn't go on the court because he
had an anxiety attack you know most
people wouldn't have been comfortable to
talk about that and yet tens of millions
of people in this country probably had
that happen this morning
and so they are people and i think that
surprises people that they have all the
same issues all the same stuff that we
all do every day
and they're able to function and do
their jobs and and maybe that's what
makes them talented on on their field of
play but
they're they're people too and and they
can have really bad days just like we
all can in really good days just like we
all can and it's important to keep that
perspective
yeah that's super super valuable insight
and and going into this covet i mean you
alluded to it
you know most professional sports have
essentially had to stop for the last
four five six months
i i'm i'm curious your view
well one how do you think this is going
to evolve i know that the nba is doing
this kind of
disney world i mean
how do you think it's going to
how do you think it's going to evolve
and let's just assume a scenario where
covid
lasts well into next year potentially
even longer
yeah so
uh
a couple things uh a bubble works
that's the good news
but it also is the bad news because if
you burst if you break the bubble
you know you can get a really bad
situation really quickly
uh two
we are woefully underprepared as a
country to test at the level we test at
with the consistency and the speed and
the accuracy we need to test at to
absent a medical solution returned to as
much as normal as possible so i compare
baseball now playing 60 games in empty
stadiums
the nfl likely to play its entire season
mostly in empty stadiums
college football being completely
cancelled probably
if not delayed until the spring
and the premier league uh in england has
announced they're going to play up to 50
capacity and i think they might even get
close to 100
because the testing in the uk has gotten
so good so quick so consistent
so accurate and and essentially
everybody has an app on their phone with
their test results so if you pass a test
you can go to the premier league game
that day uh and so testing is the answer
in the short term
everybody
you know
nirvana would be everybody tested every
day
that solves 95 of the problems we're in
right now in terms of people having a
normal life whether it's going to a
sporting event or going to a gym or
going to
get you know get a manicure it doesn't
really matter if we are testing and we
know and then being responsible in your
behavior
masks
hand washing all those things it sounds
trite
it's not political
it's fact it works keep your distance
wear a mask wash your hands you're
likely not to get covered even in an
environment where it exists and with
pervasive testing we can return to as
much as normalcy as possible until
there's a medical solution whether
that's in six months or two years as you
said and no one knows to be fair
and so
sports is
at effect if you will until that testing
exists we can't do that you know there's
enough testing to test a thousand nba
players every day that's fine or
baseball players but there's not enough
tests to test 300 million americans
every day or every other day and that's
the problem we're in and
that's really one of the great um
disappointments i have about that we
here we are five months later and you
know on the other hand we're talking
about vaccines may be coming quickly
well we're still only testing three
million people a day
and i'm no math expert i think you are
but if you have to give the vaccine
twice like most vaccines do and
certainly like the oxford one appears to
be that's 700 million injections plus or
minus
if you're only giving 3 million a day
that's 200 days before you even get
everybody vaccinated if everyone agrees
if you started today and if you had all
the vials and all that you know like
it's a real process here so like i don't
think we're prepared and and you know i
went to ucla as john wooden said failing
to prepare is preparing to fail
hmm
that's a that's a good good quote what
do you think is going to happen to the
sports i mean it sounds like the sports
industry is figuring out a way to
proceed
and i'm not an expert in the economics
of it is is is the bulk of the economics
our tv and sponsorship so even with
empty stadiums it'll it won't have the
same energy or the same feel but do you
think it'll be okay
it will be okay it won't be obviously
ideal or great
and it depends on the sports now some
sports predominantly get their revenues
from tickets and some sports
predominantly get their revenue from tv
and you can imagine the further you are
on the tv end of the spectrum
the more stable you are and the further
you are on the on the ticket end of the
spectrum the more you're gonna have
problems so a sport like tennis
well in its competitive sense feels very
safe because they are clearly far apart
from each other physically
90 of the revenue comes from ticket
sales so that's why you haven't seen a
tennis match and by the way players from
all over the world traveling all over
the world that's a problem uh and then a
sport like the nfl that has so much
revenue even though it's a majority it's
there's still a lot of ticket revenue
uh from television they can play games
and it's worth it to play games uh and
and everything else is kind of in the
middle and uh and the other piece of it
is
you can get through a year or two of
this at most uh i would tell you most
leagues are thinking about for the
2021 season for like the nba and the nhl
who start
at the end of 20 for their 2021 season
or the nfl
and major league baseball will play
complete seasons in 21 or major league
soccer i think they're figuring
maybe on a blended basis you can have 30
40 percent fans for the whole of a
season which means you start out at the
beginning of the season with no fans get
to a reduced capacity scenario and then
maybe by the end of
the 21 2021 seasons you can get pretty
close to full capacity so
and then the next year after get back to
a sense of normalcy in terms of capacity
and and filling stadiums and that's
obviously what people are hoping for
but hope doesn't solve the problems
which is why we need to focus on things
like testing and and uh and responsible
behavior
that makes a lot of sense and you know
even before a covid what what did you
think was going to be kind of the the
evolution or the future of sports you
know there's questions here about things
like vr for sports viewing from rickmon
facebook i mean is there a view that
this is how sports are going to look in
five or ten years and has covid
changed that view at all
uh a couple things i think one of the
things that hasn't so a few few things
to remember about sports uh i think it's
it's truly the only defensible piece of
the media business it matters live it
can't and won't be time shifted
it's evergreen
uh and all those things that make it
relevant it's truly local right you love
your local team it's what matters it's
kind of embedding the community in a
special way
and sports has really been for the last
25 years optimized for television
because the great majority if not almost
100 of people only consume sports on tv
i mean i think the nfl has a stat that
97 of avid nfl fans will never see a
game in person
and so you've seen the television
experience optimized the in stadium
experience relatively i mean if you want
to look 20 years ago today maybe the
stadiums are newer and nicer and the
tickets are clearly more expensive but
the experience hasn't changed a lot i
think covid will change the experience a
lot focus a lot more on the customer
experience and i'm not just talking
about health and safety protocols which
clearly need to be better i'm talking
about why are we waiting in line for 20
minutes for concessions why do we wait
lines for bathrooms
why do we have cash and slow things down
why you know
again what why isn't the experience
better so that the customer gets more
benefit all those things obviously have
health and safety benefits but they have
customer benefits so i think that will
happen for sure and then the other thing
you're gonna you have seen and we'll see
i think accelerate aggressively is
this sort of transition to
different monetizations of content so
obviously we can watch on tv free for
the most part or on some cable channels
there's going to be direct to consumer
for all the leagues there's going to be
a lot more gambling there's going to be
a lot more buying of short forms of
games there's going to be a lot more
buying of a couple minutes of the ends
of games
i think the consumption of sports is
going to continue to accelerate and be
pervasive i think the points of where
you will consume it will start to evolve
slower probably than people think and i
think ancillary ways to consume it will
probably accelerate faster than people
think
no it's super super interesting and
these conversations always go much
faster than i expect
i do want to make sure we get to the
olympics because that's fascinating
you're the chairman of the of the
olympics in los angeles in 2028 i guess
uh i guess
a bunch of questions i'll bundle
together you answered however you like
how did you get into that role why were
you interested in it and kind of where
do you see is the value of of of the
olympics like what what what you know
why are you putting the time and energy
into it the way you are
so i was asked by mayor garcetti of los
angeles to lead the bid which was the
summer of 2014 we started this process
uh it's actually something i thought was
a i joke with him that was a terrible
idea and that's why he's mayor and i'm
not but that was a terrible idea and i
thought we would lose and
it was a fool's errand and he convinced
me that he's the mayor and i don't
really have a choice so uh if i wanted
my trash picked up i better uh chair the
bid uh
so so here i am uh i happen to be a kid
of los angeles i was 10 years old in
1984 when the olympics were in my city
and i saw what an incredible experience
it was so i absolutely loved the
olympics bidding for the olympics is a
different kind of thing
and now that we have the olympics uh
look being
chair in my role in los angeles is
different than any other city on earth
we have
uh the the physical resources here
unlike any city in the world and it
doesn't start with sports stadiums which
in this day and age most people have it
really starts with usc and ucla which is
kind of counterintuitive no city on
earth has two big universities that have
athletic programs at that scale that are
in the city center 10 miles from each
other lots of cities have big
universities lots of city has great
universities some have athletics some
don't some are in the city center some
aren't la is unique and so the
combination of the scale of los angeles
uh the facilities we have on the sports
side but usc and ucla as a starting
point means we can host the olympics
without building a new venue and that's
there's no there's no sort of comma
there in a but it's legitimately we
don't have to build a new venue so
uh the athletes who we will have to
house will move into the dorms at ucla
for the olympics the media who we house
will move into the dorms at usc
we've got stadiums and practice
facilities and arenas we have i mean
there's even a model sal here if you
want to talk about a fun words problem
you know take the rubik's cube of
of uh of olympic sports and venues and
map it out in terms of transportation
logistics and all that stuff someone
would have fun with that but there's an
environment where we can host the
olympics in los angeles and not use a
single venue in orange county and by the
way you've got great basketball hockey
arena great baseball stadium
uh
not use dodger stadium and not use the
rose bowl
and still host the olympics easily and
so not saying that that's what will
happen but that's a real scenario and so
we've got an incredible
set of facilities and if we do this
right i think the economic and the
cultural and the community impact will
be staggering as part of our commitment
to the hosting the games of 28 we agreed
to fund you know covet aside we agreed
to fund 160 million dollars to subsidize
youth sports in los angeles for kids in
the city so the youth sports was free
for everybody
that's a powerful that's the biggest
investment in new sports in the history
of this country in one city
and it's a powerful statement that
literally has a chance to change this
community forever and that's just the
tip of the iceberg if we do our job
right
in executing the olympics
no that's incredible i also remember the
84 olympics very well obviously watching
it on tv and i still have the memories
if they had that tall guy to play the
alien that was a very memorable moment
for me uh and and you know it is it just
makes you uh it captures the imagination
and i you know i can't imagine how cool
it is to be at the center of that also
how stressful it is because the
logistics you just described don't seem
it don't seem easy
it is the big it is the biggest event on
earth i mean it's crazy the olympics are
the biggest event on earth by every
measure the paralympics are the third
biggest event on earth by every measure
and they will happen in the same city in
30 days
wow wow
until 2028 so i'm hopefully we'll be
through covert by then and and
everything will be back to normal and
and all of that well casey thank you so
much this was super valuable you know it
gives us a lens it gives me the lens
into a world that you know we we enjoy
but we don't understand all of what's
going on and i could have asked you
questions for several more hours but uh
you know thank you and thanks for uh you
know being being a supporter of the work
we do and i hope there's more ways that
we can we can work together and and
figure out ways to help more folks
well it's my pleasure and i appreciate
you and you know what a fan of yours and
and all that you do
i am and proud to uh have known you a
long time and be a supporter and uh
and uh your name might be a bad name in
my house because i tell my kids when
they ask me a question i could just go
on khan academy but other than that i
love you and always happy to support you
wonderful well thank you so much casey
thank you thanks for joining
well everyone uh uh thanks again for
joining what is always a fascinating
conversation i learned a lot i feel very
lucky to be able to do this and ask
people questions about the things that
are very relevant in the world i did
just get an announcement a team member
uh felipe just told me unfortunately we
were all very excited about tomorrow's
con conversation with anthony fauci just
found out that we're not sure why but
they've had to cancel we're going to see
if we can reschedule
i had a lot of questions and i know you
all had a lot of questions but i'm so
i'm sorry to say that we will not be
having the interview with dr fauci
tomorrow uh but stay tuned hopefully
we'll be able to get something else on
the books uh but with that uh thanks for
joining again and uh you'll see me at
least uh one or two more times this week
for better for worse uh you know stay
safe with all the the kovid going around
and do everything uh that casey just
mentioned about the masks and socially
distance and all that i think that is
definitely our best option so with that
i will see you later this week
you